this pride month we are celebrating
leaders in the lgbtq plus Community it's
part of our continuing series we call it
changing the game it highlights
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
Generations we have another badass for
you it's Leanne Pittsford she is the CEO
and founder of lesbians who Tech and
allies founded back in 2013 the
organization helps people in the lgbtq
community
succeed in technology Leanne welcome to
you thank you so much for having me so
let's go back to 2013.
yeah I know that was 10 years ago yes
yes what did you see or maybe didn't see
that you made you think Houston we have
a problem here and I can yeah I you know
a couple things I started my career in
the career Community I was managing the
data for the non-prof 8 campaign and
working in the Castro of San Francisco
and you know you walk around every day
and they're there were not as many women
you know it was very male it was very
white and you kind of take a pause and
think about why is that right and for me
you know managing the data I really saw
a gap in economic power right how can we
make sure women people of color
non-binary trans have more power I've
heard you say it's not really a talent
issue it's an access issue right that
means well there's I mean that's part
we're trying to show the tech business
Community what tech and business
actually look like right it's not that
we're not there and so we don't have
access to these jobs or you know we're
not being lifted up in the same way that
maybe our white CIS male counterparts
are uh lesbians you Tech is a great
great name
you're welcome to come so memorable yeah
it's actually right there it's right
there right there in the name so you
feel yeah so you feel included 110 000
members I mean this is this yeah big
organization and you started it as an
experiment
yeah I mean I so I'd been in the queer
community and it was a real struggle to
get women non-binary leaders to
participate right and we spent a lot of
work you know we go to these events and
it would mostly be like 90 male and I
was like there has to be a reason yeah
and so my hypothesis was what if we
Center lgbtq women and non-binary
leaders because frankly in the in the
queer gay lgbtq plus space we don't get
centered that often right men make more
money than women you put two men
together versus two women if you're
women of color if you're trans we often
get left out just from an economic
perspective right so it's really
important to Center us and when we did
it was like lines out the door and
people were so excited Leanne it does
feel though disheartening yeah I don't
know if it feels this way to you that uh
it feels as if we're moving backwards
often in this country when it comes to
issues yeah do you feel the same way I
mean I worked on Budweiser just look at
that yeah the backlash things that you
thought were already sort of said and
done yeah coming back to the Forefront
well you know as a younger younger gay
as a younger lesbian I worked on
marriage equality right and it was
really powerful when when Tech and
business showed up for the community and
you know frankly I want to see Corporate
America stand out more for Trans leaders
right like there's so much anti-trans
legislation we we definitely have to
show up and step up and you know
economic power can really move the
needle here and Tech business they have
a lot of power to to fight this and you
know a lot of them are but we have more
to do Liam we've got about 30 seconds
before the computer's going to deal with
all the black you've got the fourth
Annual Pride Summit uh for lesbians who
Tech coming up and allies yeah we can
tell us about it you know it's going to
have 20 000 people for from all over the
world care Swisher Sam Altman we're
going to talk about generative AI
yeah no actually we got Governor Whitmer
talking about policy Tech abortion right
we are a place where we're trying to
solve the world's biggest problems right
and coming together and find find
Solutions so it's free anyone can join
um lesbiansutech.org um join us that's
awesome that's that's quite a lineup
yeah tell them to come by here